ちょっと魔が差したというか
かけますから肉って書いてあるんですよなんかちょっと育て違い
マンキーっていうあるんですよね油性なマジックなんですけど油性マジックで
落書きせる濁酒顔にメイクすることになっちゃったんですけど
まあ何
如何なったんですけど全く落ちないということですごい困ってるんですよね今
なんか靴目にを
口紅を
その混ぜクってところに入れると落ちるっていう話を聞いたんだよ
じゃあ他にも酒が
これも作戦があるんですけどまぁとりあえず
こちらの
けれど規制しても落ちにくい館夜勤からスッと言い方ね
その緑化グロス口紅を顔に塗って
ディ生マジック落ちる買ってずっと
10金をしていきたいとおもいます
多分子供たちでう
困っている人がいると思うんです油性マジックで落書きしちゃって
どうするんだろう
だけ敷いてるなーかー山行っちゃったやつってみたよ絶対あると思うんですよ
そういう
人たちのためにもたぶんこの動画は
今までの役立つと思う
これ
ああこれかを
あれ口女ってこんなんだっけ
おーずそれください顔に撮るんですか
っぽい
ヒュー do
zumba けもんさ
ん
をぞさ
よしこのからちょっと落としていきます
甘味でわかると思うんですけど
もう
ほぼ
本戻りましたね取りますかさっきの優勢だけどまだ微妙に黒いは残ってるんですけど
そして僕の干支馬
ズボン履いてます
っていうねまず
まずですよ
異性マジックで遊ばないことが大事です
じゃあ
んをっ